Hello everybody my name is markiplier and welcome back to oxygen not included, okay, so we're picking up right where we left off
We have
Food under way we have oxygen under way we need to get more oxygen in the future and also we got a shit pit here
Which I call the shit pit I bet you'll wonder why?
Cuz it's full of shit. Okay. Yeah, that's pretty much the long the short of it anyway
it's where we're gonna dump all of our garbage and before we dump that we're gonna make sure that we got this here ah
You just have to rip the roof off of that re you raised the roof too hard
Why would you do that to me? How did you do that to me? Okay?
We also need more research because we're going under way we can't waste a single goddamn second with all this shit
Decontamination, that's important
But not as important as I think because I want to get into brute force refinement because that sounds cool
We do need a refrigerator at some point. Oh Animal Control. That's also really important. Uh you know what I'm just gonna basically
New I'm gonna pull one of these maneuvers here
I want the transit tubes. I'm not gonna lie
I want those transit to real badly
So I'm gonna let that go and then we'll have people constantly doing the you know the situation where they're
Researching at all hours of the day, and hopefully that's gonna. Help us under way, but we need a lot more oxygen
We've only produced 26 kilograms. I think it's like the rule of thumb is you need like two algae terrariums per
Per duplicated so long as they're not mouth breathers, so I need to get eight more of those at minimum
I think that's gonna help me get to where I need to go
Yeah, I think so. I think he thumb to Lanka
I think so I think I need eight more of those so I'm gonna go ahead and do that and then I shouldn't need any
More of them, okay, I'm gonna put I'm gonna put two down here to get some of this
Carbon deok sued so I'm not gonna do that two down there?
Let's see
Right there because I'm gonna put the airflow tiles underneath there and
One
No, they'd have to go in there for that one one
I
Didn't know if we need two more yeah, I guess I'll put it up here
Just just to make sure that there's no like this leakage of
Yeah, but I'm gonna put a room here
You know I really don't care that much
So why not just at the back of this room here. I know that's hard to get water to it
uh
Alright you know what I'm gonna
Do I'm gonna connect these two here?
And then eventually I'm just gonna put two more on either side of this and that that's it and that should be enough for everybody
That should be a nice path for all the water so that they're not going everywhere. Why are you in there Frankie?
What are you doing? Frankie Frankie get out of there Frankie Frankie Frankie?
All right, whatever so we got the airflow tiles will research more research more research
So then we need to get refrigeration at some point, but if they're on the path to go over to that thing
Maybe I should do this more piecemeal
artistic
Expression man good think I got all these good researchers going on here. Oh, yeah jobs wait
I need to make sure that the dumbass Frankie doesn't do that and nobody else does art besides
Frankie because she's a genius at it a letter that a little no one's gonna cook besides raw wood all right NEMA
You are a fighting master. Okay, all right doing good doing good doing good so the next step. I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna make a food facility as soon as that's done. Which is very soon. Also. I'm gonna put a statue in the shitter
uh-huh yeah
I probably should have put at least one of the algae terrariums in here just a little people can hold their breath
I mean there's gonna be polluted oxygen in there anyway, so what does it matter as soon as I get to deodorizer?
That's what I'm gonna do for that so I've got enough water for right now
I need to get a filtration system at some point there's oxygen flow in there. We've got
I'm willing to bet that after this gets through one more cycle. What is with your red dots of death? I don't like it
Don't like it none, but I'm gonna create a mess hall up here so that they have a unified place to eat
Mmm. I'm gonna need Animal Control at some point
meal prep
agriculture, let's go for animal control just so we can get those hatches out of there then we can put them into one place and
then hopefully
hopefully that means we'll have a
Depository 'um of things that we need to do now. I don't know if I can instruct anyone to put things
zum-zum were but if I put storage containers
If I put storage containers in there they shouldn't I think they're able to eat from the storage containers
I'm not on represent sure about that, but something tells me that that is a thing that can definitely happen
I have nothing to base that off of but my own intuition in my own
She wrote spa. I don't know what quits plays, but I got a lot of it
They're doing that alright time for the mess hall. We're gonna make this so I want the mess hall to be
The biggest lesson that I've learned in all this is that I need to stop
Being such a douche all the time
This is a general statement about my own life, but I need to stop being such a douche in that
I have this really bad habit of
trying to wire the entirety of
My base to one power supply when that's not entirely necessary. I can have small power supplies which is like
That's the whole point this it's like the lesson to be learned. Is these wires will overload if you power them too much
Eventually if you have a heavy watt and a unified power supply
Yeah, sure if you have a big project
But each thing can be piecemeal like the mess hall can have its own power supply
I can create like the the manual generators up here to power something
Down there like it's just that's just what it should be right you know
That's what it should be, but I don't do that because I'm real dumb
real dumb, and then you're just a small amount of battery and
HUBO the big ooh, and then Oh wouldn't you know it we got ourselves a mess hall going on here alright?
So now that we got that I'm gonna make the furniture is gonna be all the cooking is gonna be in the back WAIS block
is
Wouldn't melt
Don't melt right though wouldn't that melt I'm gonna put up. I'm gonna pull one of these in the shitter there we go
That's good, and I'm gonna put a blank canvas over your
right ear
There and there no no no no no no no no no I ain't gonna work like that and ain't gonna work
But I put them right here and here there. We are
There we are now that is refined once we got that we're gonna make the mess hall with decoration in mind
Because these extend eight blocks
So what do we have here an uneven number?
Shit, yeah, I'll just extend the room a little bit longer. I like symmetry
yeah, okay, so now that we got that let's establish that the
Front end of this bullshit is gonna be the actual eating area
With a one two three fewer. We only need five, but let's plan former
You know why not why not actually not not so close to the door
We'll have six because I think eventually I will have six people six is a nice even number but for right now
I want to make sure that we got enough to be able to do
What we got to do so that decorum is gonna be good so in the background here. We're gonna put the
Refrain badge a door or also are they researching anything. Oh good there. Okay? We're gonna put the fumble later
Refrigerators gonna be oh yeah the refrigerator offers decor as well, so the refrigerator is gonna be right there and right there
We're gonna know. I'm not gonna. That's too much power
I forgot that those actually take a lot of power so a lot of battery on this one is gonna be a good thing
Might as well double up on battery right off the bat
Just just in case okay, and then we're gonna need the food prep got the smack smack and grill right there
That and then the microbe yeah, we don't need two of those
And then a little bit little bit little bit little bit little bit little bit little bit little bit
Yeah, we're gonna put ration box back here because that's gonna be the the housing
for the food
You better be good if I'm gonna get you you're gonna be good all right Nisbet. No oh God Ruby Ruby
Oh my god, Ruby Ruby Ruby
Three negative traits, but so many positive oh my god Ruby
You are Ruby. You are a walking disaster
Ruby you're just a walking I
Like you the tryptophan gas for phobias squeamish can't aid can't cook can't dig
What can you do Ruby Ruby?
What can you do you've got great cooking skills?
But can't cook you can't aid you got medicine good tinker and in athletics Ruby you got so much going
not going for it, but you know I can't help, but like your Ruby I
Think I think I can set you to a very specific purpose you can't do all these things. That's fine
You know that's fine cuz I'm gonna
I'm gonna make I'm gonna make sure Ruby Ruby here Ruby's Ruby won me over just sheer
I never usually go for people like that but Ruby
Something about Ruby look at that Ruby can still do a ton of shit
And do it well so Ruby you ain't gonna do that you ain't gonna. Worry about dissing fit. I you can disinfect. That's cool
That's true. Are you ain't gonna? Worry about harvesting you sweep you deliver you maintain repair
Power hydro fin Ruby's gonna be a valuable addition to this team Ruby's got a lot of skills doesn't have a lot of expectations
Ruby I'm really excited about this Ruby
I have a funny feeling you're gonna be uh invaluable member to the team
All right
So now that we got that underway and all we need to do now is hook up the power for these bad boys we get
The research that just finished they're a blam-blam-blam- what other research uh?
Control greats. Okay. That's good because somewhere in here
Where's Animal Control don't pause where's Animal Control whoo fertilizers is?
All righty, then I don't know if I need fertilizer that badly all right animal control uh
Aerial creature lure creature trap. I don't have plastic. I can't make any of that shit. I don't have plastic well
That was a waste of my time well let's go for plastic
But I'm not gonna be able to get plastic because it don't have anything all this probably needs plastic
I'm not gonna be able to get plastic
Let's go for sanitation decontamination anyway. That's that's always a good one as far as I know so
Probably gonna be all right if it's not then
Pepper bread stuffed berry, I don't have any of those pickled mule it's still grizzly. Why would I do that man?
I can't do any of this shit
Mush fry I don't know I don't want that oh shit. I forgot I need to make another bed all right
I've officially fucked myself because I keep doing this where I get like our duplicate
duplicate
Friends friends friends and it's like there's no reason to do any of that so the other thing
I got to do is I got to get the decor in order because things are looking a bit bleak in here
So let's get this decor up and running so we need to get let's just strew these bad boys
Here here, they're here. Oh look at the symmetry on that oh
I love it. I love it. Love it. Love it. Love it. Okay, so I'm gonna get you some decor here
Because this ain't gonna do
Nothing for you all right doodly-doo digital Italy man these guys are
Attentive. I really do appreciate it when people are on task and these guys are on task and you know what I'm even
Gonna put a little more a hey about I know it's I know
this is a little cluttered a lot of the decorum problems are coming from just this being cluttered, but I
Will get this underway whiten the hell
What just oh?
That's why well. That's stupid
God damn it put everything in there get all of it in the stupid thing and then sweep this stupid thing
Look at this swept get all this swept get all that shit swept sweep it. You sweep that up
Alright, cuz that's sweeping without sweeping. It ruins a lot of the decorum. So they're gonna go for a bit
I'm gonna leave them to it all I'll just let them go because they're gonna be good for a bit
We're not doing enough oxygen
But we're close I need to get two more of those things before we're even out from the loss of adding
The other people so we need 12 in total basically
But we are still doing pretty decent and just to put one up here to put one right there
I'm eventually gonna put one right there
Shit, I can't make that that's fine. I'll put some lights where's lice loaf
Doesn't say it can put a life. What doesn't say can have lice loaf in here
I do want to get the life's loaf glowing, but what's even the point right? I mean to be perfectly honest like
lice is
Edible, and it's not that bad. I mean Ruby's the only one right now
That's causing up a stink and to be perfectly honest Ruby Ruby
You've got problems as it is I'll take this as a boon. You know kind of a benefit going on here
I guess oh wait how about yet? Get rid of the polluted water? Oh?
Yeah, are we doing on germs we we death-defying?
Oh, no, I row in fro and get that out of your body right now mister. Oh
Rowan goddamnit Rowan get that out of your body right now
Did you not wash your hands? Did you eat mock root? That was in the shitter?
Hole if you did you're a sack of shit yourself, and I'm sorry, but you just are alright, so I'm gonna do something risky
I'm gonna go get a drink
Hopefully everything's still here when I get back
if it ain't
Then oopsy poopsy
they all die, but I think it'll be good in fact ah
There we go now. They're gonna go for alright
All right are they dead
They seem a little dead ha the oxygen thing. I forgot about that
Okay, we need oxygen flowing out of one place
That is gonna be beefy enough
To get everywhere I'm thinking if I put
one of these
Yeah
one of these here in the middle ish oh
I pause sorry do air flow tiles
Beneath here, maybe more like this. No no no that's good kind of like right here
Get a power system kind of like one of these because I don't want them to have to run in a place. That's gonna be
Shitty for them also, this is gonna heat up that area. Okay. I could just connect v's I
mean, I'm remiss to connect to everything but I could connect this I
Do I need to do though I?
Don't really need to you know what actually I think I think because of
The decor from the printing pod, which I'm pretty sure bleeds through that yeah, it does. I think it's gonna be okay
Yes, it'll be fine
It'll be fine. It won't be that shitty. I'll put another painting. It's a pretty
Beautiful who's got anything to worry about that that's beautiful. That's a be a thing of beauty right there. All right?
also
The decorum is greatly improved considering that we've gotten rid of all the bullshit that we didn't need it
like the stuff on the floor and now they're well on their way to success and love and why
Alright, so once this mess. Hall is up and running actually is the mess hall come on man
What does it need one table no industrial machinery minimum size 12?
no industrial machinery Oh
Does that mean like the kitchen?
Yeah, oh, yeah, I'm not gonna pick anybody man
If I wanted to pick somebody I'd have to mercilessly murder the one I didn't want to
Survive so that I don't have to go through that they would have to be they would have to be pretty
Amazing liked Rivaldo Auto Lehrer you guys are good at all and that's wonderful
But you're not amazing enough for me to have to murder one of my already their
duplicates I don't want to do that that sounds horrible and
No, we're not gonna go for that so that's all I have to say about that all right so the only thing I know about
This room is like
minimum 12 tiles that is
big
That's a honker all right, but what I'm gonna. Do is I'm gonna test this out. I'm gonna get rid of the
Weight what's the barracks no industrial machine, but there's no it does your Oh does that count as an industrial machine
Oh
Wait no it's too big oh
Why is it too big?
That's stupid. You're stupid. You know what I'm gonna. Get rid of I know how to beat this
I know how to beat the system. We're gonna get rid of you. We're gonna get rid of you
We're gonna plant the rest of these things cuz I know we got more of those
How we doing on food good Greg Greg Greg great? Okay?
They're rid of you get rid of you plant you plant you go away
I don't want to reject all get out of there get out of there. I don't you that's gone. This is gone
I'll listen to the music that's some nice music
We're gonna pull one of these here, we're gonna wall this off as if it never existed because there never did it
We're all just gonna pretend like it's not there
Yeah, that's how I'd like to deal with all my problems, so I think once I do that
And then I'm gonna figure out why this one is not a room. Oh, it's not an enclosed space yet oh
Well this is priorities because I am an impatient son of a bitch now hopefully once that's enclosed
It'll be hunky-dory and everything will be wonderful
Yeah, I say that about all my things everything will be hunky-dory when I just get this one thing to fix it oh I can't
wait for everything to be
Solved man life is such a wonderful adventure ain't it
Shit, we got to get it. Yeah get all this shit in the refrigerator. I said I got to get more refrigerator anyway
Yeah, not a Y then why does the goddamn refrigerator take so much goddamn power? Oh actually no. They reduce it?
I think they've reduced it actually because it used to take it like 240 watts. Yeah
Now it's only 120 watts. Hell. Yeah, okay, so fucker the ration box. We don't need that if you get the ration box
Alright is this, uhh
Whoa exosuit overlay okay? All right sure. Yaaaay
Salmon recovery bonus, that's good cuz we got a Brax
Oh, hell, yeah, hell. Yeah, okay, so now that we got that
That's good, which means they we're gonna be able to
Have a little bit of a stamina bonus. We're gonna have this is this a room yet
Yes
Mess-hall baby. All right. Everybody's got tables - we're not gonna get any more people than six
So that's all we need so Rowan are you happy finally arey?
Meemaw I know me ma. You've seen pretty much everything and nothing shocks you at this point, but 'kay
I gotta admit it's not bad, right Meemaw?
It's not bad. Yeah, whatever. They'll get it. Why is Oh goddamn? Why is it there?
Please get this at a level six priority so that you dump out the pissed water. Thank you. No. Oh good actually
That's good. You picked that up, and then you wash your hands. It's good. It's very good. Okay nice bathroom
Is it really a nice bathroom? I dunno if, pfft, I don't know if I'd call this bathroom nice
It's got a mediocre sculpture here very quaint hmm
Masterpieces now one of these days are gonna. Get that underway because we do need more uh actually no wait
It's just said we didn't need more oxygen. Oh the cycle is over
So wouldn't have said anyway. Did all this did all those hatches like move up or something I dunno okay
So what are we doing on research?
We're almost at transit tubes, but I still don't think we're gonna be able to build that because there's uh
I they're probably just gonna all need plastic and in order to get plastic we need to get oil and in order to get oil
We need to dig way too deep just we can't do it
So that's gonna come way way way later, but for now
We make do okay. We're off our oxygen target by just a little bit if we do that
I can get rid of some of these which means it will save water overall because
Water, I'm still a little bit worried about water
I mean water is gonna be a little bit better with filtration systems and all that stuff
But I'd rather not push it you know to the limit. You know I don't want
I don't want to give and I'm gonna give myself a heart attack here. Just over water
Which is always what happens because this whole place like every little bit of it like if there if you don't have water like nyeaah
You're so incredibly boned like this non-stop
Just boned hundred twenty watts hey they dropped the power requirement that one to hell yeah, I mean about damn time
Oh, also I should replace these with the bigger battery, that would be smart of me
Oh, no, you're not gonna be able to do your research
Nnooow
Okay, put that there. There we go. Stinky what are you doing? Stinky stop that stinky stop, stop
It's not build yet Stinky. What are you doing? Alright who's wait?
Let's see if we can refine the jobs down because if we're only gonna have six
Then I'm definitely gonna want to try to refine that ehh, no one's really the best at building well
Let's make sure Rowan doesn't build. Rowan's digging. Let's make sure, who's bad at digging? Frankie you no dig
One of these guys dig. Deliver you're not very ath- Meemaw
I love you to death really do we all do everyone here does love you to death but you're not very athletic so we're gonna
Gonna, take you off the delivery crew if that's if that's okay all right
Okay, all right, then pretty sure you're gonna be fine with that okay, farming. I didn't even know farming was
Farming is a different skill? That used to be digging. Oh, okay. Well I guess that's good, wait
Why are they stifled cuz there's not enough oxygen? Did you get this going yet? God damn it, you
Didn't you didn't you didn't you didn't you sack of shit you didn't priority 9, baby
Priority 9 that bad boy all right get that
Whirlybird going. Get that out of there
Alright, we need to get more airflow tiles uuum we need air flow into there
Well these pneumatic doors are just like they allow air through, so it's not really that bad
But we should at least get air flow tiles going up through the top if this is gonna be
The way I think this is gonna be at least space them out a little bit goodly
I don't like right there and there and there and
Yeah, that'll do
Okay, they should have an 'eeeir we go there. We go that a baby. Oh that's barely any power
Oh, that's a thing of beauty right there
I know it's gonna cause some heat, but yeah, you know c'est la vie c'est la Heat
It is what it is, and we can't deal with it right now, but what we will deal with in the future is
everything else
So we got a fridge, er, we got our fridges up and running which means that we got our food being refrigerated
Which means that that's gonna be not a problem for the immediate future
We've got enough meal life being... meal lice being produced
We will eventually get rid of these and we'll move them elsewhere because that's not exactly the best place for them
but it is good enough for now and uh
Then we've got another water supply over here, but that might be contaminated. Oh, no that's right 'cause slime lung can't travel through water
food poisoning can and does slime lung only travels in air and solid
But it does not affect water so slime lung is never a factor when you're dealing with
Filtration through the polluted water in there. The next step will be to get filtration system
It looks like there's a good bit over here, and I will get that underway
For that one, but that is all the time that I got for this episode, so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down the comments below
I am gonna play more of this 'cause I just frickin' love the game you know
I just love love love the game so much, and I can't help but love it cuz there's so much to love about it
So thank you everybody so much for watching. We are gonna survive this one
We're gonna be we're gonna be building a colony that is gonna be worthy
Of the Markiplier name, so thanks again and as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-Bye!